>>Bonnie: So here we are, right
here at Clearfield High School,
and you look at these
pollution plumes,
a lot of you guys live
in this area right here.
You could possibly have the pollution
plumes underneath your homes.
>>Narrator: Chemistry
and biology students
at Clearfield High School are
personally involved in their studies,
because they impact the
health of their community.
>>Anthony: And there's actually some
areas that are contaminated so bad,
that the fumes rise up into the
basements of people's houses,
and so they get these TCE fumes
in their house, and that can lead
to cancer and other
serious illnesses.
>>Narrator: The source
of the pollution is
nearby Hill Air Force Base,
on the outskirts of Salt Lake City.
>>Man: We overhaul C-130s,
that's the big planes behind you,
if you don't know what they are.
>>Narrator: It is the largest
employer in the state of Utah,
but it also generates
about four million pounds
of hazardous waste each year.
>>Man: This looks like it's a
perfectly separate liquid here,
but this water up here still
contains trichloroethylene compounds
that far exceed the levels
that we have to clean up to.
>>Bonnie: How do you
track the disposal
and make sure they didn't
disappear from the facility?
>>Narrator: Students in Bonnie
Bourgeous' class have been studying
the situation and monitoring
the pollution since 2006.
>>Bonnie: Actually getting to go out
and collect the data in the field,
and getting to see some of the
sites that we were able to visit
on our field trip, it just makes
it so that they understand that,
you know, if you affect one thing,
that you do have consequences
for what you do.
And they get to see man's
impact on the environment.
>>Man: By this stage, most of the
metals should have been removed.
The only thing that's left
at this stage will be the
volatile organic compounds that--
>>Narrator: Students follow the trail
of the toxic waste from the base
through various stages
of purification,
to a canal at the local
water treatment plant.
>>Student: We are measuring
the turbidity of the water,
which basically means, how clear
it is, and how many different kinds
of particles are in the water.
>>Narrator: There, they work in
teams to gauge the water quality.
>>Student: I'm kicking up the dirt,
and then Chandler is
catching everything I kick up,
so that we can identify it.
>>Whitney: We were testing the
water for nitrogen, oxygen, the Ph,
the temperature, the light source.
>>So go into the experiment.
>>Our group used the
computer the most.
>>Narrator: The tablet computers
came from a technology grant
that included probes and software.
>>Student: It leveled out.
>>Student: Trevor, I'm going
to tell you to take it out in
about 20 seconds, so wait until
I tell you to take it out.
>>Massiell: What the
computer allows us to do,
isn't it gain up to hundreds
of readings within seconds,
or even a tenth of a second,
rather than the Ph strip,
where you can just put it in
the water and have one reading.
So that-- the computer is
really convenient for that.
>>Student: That's the Ph?
>>Bonnie: They're able to see
immediately what the data is,
and then you can do the
statistical analysis,
and determine whether the
lab results are good or not,
and what they need to change.
And they can see and compare two
data, right next to each other.
And so it makes it real life.
>>Student: How far down?
>>Student: Just barely in.
>>Student: The percentage of error
will be less with the technology,
and that helps with our calculations
that we'll do in our presentations
that we make, the reports
that we write.
>>Bonnie: Remember, so there's a lot
of things you're being graded on.
So we've done the planning,
and we've done the action.
Now we need to do the follow up.
>>Narrator: Once students complete
their research, and analyze the data,
they write reports that are sent
to both Hill Air Force Base,
and the International
Baccalaureate Program,
which awards them college
credit for their work.
>>Bonnie: And I teach the same
subjects on A day and B day,
and so on A day, I did
without the technology, B day,
I did it with the technology.
And so I taught exactly the same
stuff, but their understanding
and the concepts went
up by about 20 percent
when they were taught
with the technology.
>>Narrator: For Bourgeous,
the portable computer
and projector were particularly
handy when she had to hold her class
in the school cafeteria while
her science lab was remodeled.
>>Bonnie: I wouldn't
have been able to survive
without the projector and the laptop.
The new definition of portable
classroom was on my back,
I'd carry my laptop and my backpack
and with the projector being small,
it made it so I could get
from classroom to classroom,
and be able to have that
information for the students.
>>Teacher: Hey, what are
some potential problems,
and some solutions for
creating a debate website?
>>John: Technology is
a great enhancing tool
to what the students
get in a classroom.
Our students can gain more
than they ever used to,
because there's more
information available,
not only because it's
accessible to them,
but it's more interesting to them.
>>Student: The Zhou people
conquered the Shang people--
>>Narrator: In teacher, Paulette
Hopfenbeck's World History class,
students experience a wider world
with the improved access
to technology.
>>Paulette: One of my classes,
I took on a virtual field
trip of a World War I trench.
And by showing them that, all of a
sudden, it became more real to them.
They looked at that and said,
I cannot imagine living in that
for a couple of years in a war.
I couldn't have done
that another way.
>>Does war impact environment?
How so?
>>So personally, the
technology it's been wonderful,
and I know the other teachers
in the building are very excited
about integrating it, and
it makes it possible for us
to do more cross-curricular things,
because we have similar
equipment, and we're using it.
>>Think about the silk road, because
it reaches all the way to Europe.
Is that another environmental impact?
>>Bonnie: It's been incredible to
watch the students involvement,
and their interest levels
increase, as they get to do--
it's like toys to them, but they
think they're toys at first,
but then they realize that
these really are tools,
and they do enhance our
learning and understanding,
and it makes it become real
life, rather than doing 30,
60, 90 triangles for trig.
I mean, you know, that
gets really boring,
and so that technology can bring
this alive for the students.
>>Student: Whitney, can
you type in Ph Sewer One?
>>Narrator: For more
information about,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.